we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
increasingly people in the audience are
very concerned about my pillow ceo mike
lindell's health we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines we
have all noticed that he seems
particularly hopped up lately and here
is a caller who says pillow is sick
pillow is sick
hi david in lieu of last night's um
hopefully one of the final hearings of
january to 6th yeah i was hoping that
you might really go a little bit lighter
on mike lindell the man is ill
and i don't want to see him harm himself
and we need to be as compassionate as we
can for him hopefully he's going to
realize what's going on and he's going
to do a big 180
and i think the man is going to support
uh well
the country has actually made fun of him
for snapping and we need to shape up as
human beings and realize that he's one
of us
in spite of the fact we're he's just
sick and we need to take care of him
thanks bye there is no question
whatsoever that something is very wrong
with mike pillow now there has been
speculation that he's back on drugs i
don't know if that's the case it's not
funny it's sad it's a medical problem
and he needs help
uh there is speculation that
this insanity over the last two years of
flying all around the country to every
trump rally and doing his symposium and
all of these different things has just
strained his relationship with his
family and that that's kind of uh what
we are seeing something is very clearly
wrong with the guy and early on we would
wonder does mike pillow believe this
stuff or doesn't he and at first i
thought at first i thought it was sort
of an act
it doesn't seem like an act at this
point and i interviewed him and i
interacted with him a little bit behind
the scenes and also saw how he interacts
with his staff
something seems off with the guy so
listen i hope he gets the help that he
needs uh we will to the extent that he
still has a following
i mean listen what as i've said before
when you've got a crazy guy yelling in
the subway
and they don't have the following to
become president or become adjacent to
the president you don't think about it
too much
when you have a country that will see a
guy who is so obviously unhinged
and say this guy is a genius this guy's
going to save us and then the former
president invites him to his rallies or
maybe he's not invited but welcomed and
shouted out
then you say it's more about the
followers than it is the guy and that
certainly seems to be the case with mike
pillow so hopefully he gets the help he
needs seems like it's a lot of it we
have a great bonus show planned for you
today a republican lawmaker
voted against same-sex marriage
and then three days later went to his
gay son's gay wedding
what
yeah
russia says it will quit the
international space station after 2024
and the teen activist who was body
shamed by republican congressman matt
gates has received more than twenty
eight thousand dollars in donations for
her work
three incredible stories all on today's
bonus show you can sign up at
joinpackman.com get instant access
we will see you then